leute herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge einen tag persönlicher koch heute
mal wieder eine ganz besondere folge ich
beim mag und die folge ist nicht nur
besonders weil wir uns quasi jetzt auch
zum ersten mal sehen ob diese art und
weise sondern das hier ist was heute ab
geht es wird alles schaaf das habe ich
bei amazon bestellt so carolina flocken
bis zu 22 millionen scoville mag liebt
scharfes essen und wir fangen den tag an
mit einem scharfen online nicht weiter
ehrlich ein bisschen überrascht also ich
wusste das mag auf kaffee experte ist
eine richtig schöne maschine und mühle
aber er hat sogar seine eigene
kaffeesorte seine eigene rüstung das
heißt wir uns gleich darauf bestehen
dass ich von ihm kaffee gemacht bekommen
gewiss auch sehr und dann bin ich sehr
gespannt wie der schmeckt vielleicht
weiß kaum noch einpacken von seinem café
wir sind schon die einkäufe ich habe
alles mögliche geholt unter anderem das
tier drin ein ganzer fisch den gibt's
heute mittag
er kann jetzt meinen kühlschrank habe
ich habe mit seinen küchen eingerichtet
damit ihr auch zu sehen könnte man sie
als erste um die chance live arbeiten im
moment bzw
ich hab in den so einfach nur den einen
das geben wir gleich alles mit dem die
fahne machen schwer das augenlicht den
schneiden wir einfach mal so entscheiden
entscheiden
also leute falls ihr euch nicht so
auskennen mit so scoville einheiten und
sowas das was jetzt gerade gezeigt hatte
die 22 millionen gewählt sind wirklich
bescheuert viel und markt geht es um mit
der zunge also der ist wirklich nicht
von dieser welt etwas schärfer angeht
braucht er auch nur die halbe da
natürlich chili insbesondere aus
mittagessen freut mich so viel kann ich
sagen es kann nicht viel wald ist
vorbereiten und jetzt der star der show
you tube hallo läuft bestens
in chili anhörung gekommen ist aber
sogar für mich ein super schaut halt die
natürlich schauten kommt wieder die
flocken kommen auf jeden fall auch schon
zum einsatz dazu noch eine kleine
überraschung beim bäcker geholt okay
also das reflektiert natürlich schnell
wir machen uns die füllung hat irland
mit dem zusammen das kommt jetzt zum
einsatz ich mal dran das ist schon so
dass das auf jeden fall mehr richtig
schön italienische mutter im kühlschrank
kann ich mir ein bisschen brutal die
handel zum preis werden das jährliche
schnell die eier man recht ist maßlos
zeitungsbericht zum triple double mit
den berichten viele toten gerochen habe
und dann gehen wir auch schon mal die
ersten sachen in die pfanne wie wir
sagen ja sie können wir auf jeden fall
auch mit 1000
also setzt temperatur dann geben wir
jetzt das eigenheim und ab jetzt schon
das ganze konstant in bewegung halten
und rühren
aber wir fahren da nicht heiß genug aber
ich hatte die höchste stufe großer
fläche wahrscheinlich muss ich ein
bisschen auspacken lassen gebe ich jetzt
auch noch ein bisschen käse drauf dann
leute ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt
ein bisschen schlechtes gefühl mag seite
von light kommen noch die psyche blocken
jetzt fertig so die seiten und sterbe
komplett dann probieren wir das ganze
mal an zu lockern von allen seiten
ja ok aber wenn wir das ganze gleich
geschickt auf den teller legen was das
vielleicht sollten wir es mal das ist
leider ein bisschen zu fallen und dann
hab ich noch so richtig schön ist brot
geholt panne mit karte noch mal richtig
heiß weiter sind wir auch gleich so weit
so leute da sitzen wir ich hoffe ich
habe die hälfte erwischte in der nicht
unglaublich viele kölner rapper ist wir
haben hier ein komplett mit südafrika
trip trompeter also dran dann haben wir
einen oliven ring das waren echte
überraschung
gefällt dir ich habe mich auf jeden fall
hier inspirieren marcks gerne die
orientalische später sein dass uns
loslegen
du kannst einfach gerne den ersten
bissen nämlich viel sagen ob ich nicht
einmal aus kannst in ruhe frühstücken
und wir sehen und zwar zu bewerten ob
die kamera das schon auf aber sag noch
mal dass moment sehr gut hinbekommen und
die schärfe
ich meine es mag märkte gibt also wer
mit fertig gefrühstückt und was mir
besonders gut gefallen hat war das
eigentlich zu trocken ist ja etwas zu
gut hinbekommen es ist somit also mit
dem kunden sofort spaß gemacht wo ja
auch schon gehört schon papa matthias
ist nicht ganz so einfach besonders weil
wir hier halt diese ktg und sowas dann
hat ein zug nur das muss ja alles
irgendwie aber dann hat bestimmt sein
das hat mir sehr gut gefallen die
schärfe also diese uniformen und
eingemachtes haben eigentlich ist auch
ganz gut getroffen
das bald sind sie zu schlagen weiß es
war eigentlich für den normen sowie ein
espresso war perfekt gewürzt leute ich
habe an der stelle wo ist getrennt habe
hatte ich noch ein paar flocken und ich
habe eine erste gabe und mag hat dadurch
die zehnfache menge karten für den
morgen die note ich meine so gesehen ich
wüsste jetzt nicht was man an dem
gericht hat noch verbessern könnte in
dem sinne
naja ich szenen sagen oh ja es ist halt
du hast das omelett sehr sehr feiner das
boot weil eine perfekte die menge auf
gut und hat super bauleute perfekt das
nenne ich mal nen guten start in den tag
wir sehen uns zum mittagessen gibt es
zwischen und sachkosten sowie sind kurz
vor mittag essen ich habe noch ein paar
besorgungen gemacht und man macht mir
einen kaffee er ist kein kaffee espresso
bekomme ich bin schon der kapitän
weil ich aber auch meine ich habe so
hart eingestellt habe
erst richtig lecker schmeckt mit milch
ein kräftiger zusätzlich zugriff nehmen
mache ich auch gern nach hast du
aufrecht da geht's um toppen ich freue
mich richtig raus kommen weil es ist was
ganz neues für mich an ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt ja ich habe jetzt energie leute
seine boni komme ich verlinkt die mache
ich nur noch modus ich habe meine marx
kaffeebohnen unten rein und ihr fangt an
mit dem mittag ist schon alles
vorbereitet es gibt heute mittag eine
rose gerade in der salzkruste gebacken
und dazu einen kurs kurs kichererbsen
das sage ich so leise bei markt
überrascht lasst uns loslegen hier
erstmal damit ihr check was abgeht hier
ist unsere so gerade richtig groß die
wurde schon erschöpft vom fischverkäufer
sollte nicht heute war und das wird auf
jeden fall super lecker hab noch nie so
gemacht ich habe mir das spiel
angeschaut
ziemlich gut wie es geht das ist auch so
ein klassisches essen was ultra-fans sie
klingt aber wir brauchen wenn ich alles
richtig verstanden habe insgesamt gerade
mal eine dreiviertelstunde
wir fangen alle dem wir die salzkruste
vorbereiten für die orale drei kilogramm
groß mehr seit sie gehen dazu jetzt vier
eiweiß und 75 milliliter wasser
das kenne ich jetzt alles durch hier ist
unsere salz mischung gespräch kurz zur
seite
und dann bereiten wir auch schon alles
für die füllung der dorade vor eine bio
zitrone und schneiden sie ihnen scheiben
dann schnappe ich mir jetzt reicht wohl
auch so wenig hochziehen geschält sind
eines menschen wie dir auch noch mal so
kommen nämlich gleich als ganze in den
fisch hinein und würzen so von innen das
fleisch darf hier sollen wir nicht tun
ja ein bisschen rosmarin und dann können
jetzt auch schon daran machen die gerade
zu füllen die throne knoblauchzehen
rosmarie schnappt euch hier unsere
backblech und dann fahren wir jetzt
quasi eine plattform für lokale beiden
zentimeter hoch dann haben wir unseren
fisch größe passt perfekt die
schwarz-weiße schaut hin ein bisschen
drüber das ist überhaupt kein problem
bei erstmal sowieso nicht mit und dann
fangen wir auch schon an den fisch zu
bedecken unserem kleinen salzer außen zu
fahren wo ich liebe es wirklich in sich
meine gäste hier in dem format solche
sachen wünschen wirklich noch was lernen
und war das neues mache und sorgte das
gebe ich jetzt in den ofen und zwar für
mindestens eine halbe stunde übrigen 200
grad ober unterhitze 200 milliliter
wasser machen wir heiß darin sind die
gleich ein bisschen gemüse
früher auf und zwar einen esslöffel
verkleinert ob die nicht gerade hatte
der ist scheinbar nicht induktions fähig
ist schon schön heiß geworden
mit 200 gramm kuskus lassen jetzt
einfach quellen in der brühe als
nächstes machen welche gene cretz für
unseren salat und dafür brauchen wir
zitronen sagt heinz zwei drei vier fünf
sechs esslöffel von dem zitronensaft
einer halb teelöffel honig sechs
esslöffel olivenöl beim kuss war es auf
jeden fall ein bisschen zu wenig wasser
ich habe jetzt immer noch ein bisschen
was dazu geben und dann kommt jetzt
unser laden noch etwas zu sambal olek da
habe ich dann ins marx portion nochmal
bisschen mehr rein aber hier gebe ich
jetzt erstmal so in gestrichenen
teelöffel hinein und verrühren wir das
ganz so gut wie 27 bisschen knoblauch
wir mal auf zwei knoblauchzehen und dann
hatte ich den ganz frei nehmen jetzt
hier drei frühlingszwiebeln und die
schneiden jetzt in feine ringe
ich glaube es ist auch ein essen das
meiner mama zum beispiel sehr gut
gefallen würde
dann haben wir noch etwas gut schneiden
wir oben und nach und vierteln die
gurken sowie gefährdet ist wenn wir sie
in dünne scheiben sowie eine reiche doch
auf jeden fall so dass ich hier meine
kichererbsen ich bitten wir fragt und
ich spiele auch mal im sieb drüber na
dann holen wir mal rüber dann gebe ich
die kirche reaktion nation
dazu kommen dieser geschnittenes gemüse
und dann kommt auch schon unsere den weg
das alles kommt der wenigen verwendet
ich habe gerade alles in kleinen
schüssel hinaus geben hier ist unendlich
viel sagen weil olaf drin und carolina
flottenverbrauch probiert meine nase
läuft ohne ende und sie kommen was jetzt
auf dem tisch geworden
das sind aber auch ordentliche viel
papier 100 mal gezeigt wie man
vernünftig fisch filetiert der werde
jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
jetzt auch gleich schon laufen kriegt
noch ein bisschen frische zitrone über
den fisch und du kriegst mal ein
bisschen apa geschäftsführer peter
mantik also die halbseitig noch bedienen
falls du noch was braucht ich freue mich
darauf jetzt war ich halt etwas leichter
ist jetzt für den mittag zu den daten
manuell leistungsfähig ist weil sonst
wenn wir das was wir später meisten
werden dann werden wir auf jeden fall
glaube ich nämlich auch das wird jetzt
sehr sehr gut passen
du kannst einfach nicht so viel sagen
dann sehen was vielleicht so bewertung
also daran mag jeweils leer gefegt bin
gespannt was du sagst ich habe auch
unter anderem nachschlag er habe das
nicht gesehen aber der fisch war
exzellent und dass das besondere jetzt
bei denen ist denn wenn man es
zubereitet du kannst nicht nach erst du
musst die druckvoller ist ja fast so
alles gepasst und es war wirklich ein
voller erfolg wir haben den leckeren
couscous salat gehabt sehr schöner und
wenn es alles klein geschnitten und
sowas hat gut geschmeckt war frisch dazu
und alles andere hat funktioniert
wirklich ist eine ganz ganz ganz tolle
kombinationen
wenn ihr mal ein projekt sucht für für
sonntags zum beispiel jawohl ich den
fisch durch grobes meersalz das macht
wirklich spaß und das produkt am ende
ist es schon toll also wieder zehn von
zehn glaub ich muss noch mal alles geben
das abendessen wir sehen heute abend
geht es dann kommt auch zum abendessen
es gibt heute abend burger ich habe mir
schon oft einfach persönlicher kaufen
aber es gibt ihn also sondern
variationen deshalb dran bleiben auch
eine zubereitungsarten die bisher nicht
hatten auch eine die ihr vielleicht
tausende könnt ich sage ich bin schon
topf aufgestellt mit wasser erst
passiert kartoffeln stellen so
kartoffeln sind geschält und ich
schneide sie jetzt in gleichgroße stücke
jetzt wasser zum kochen da sie jetzt mal
stellt der kreis und
dazu kommt jetzt ein teelöffel
backpulver parallel hier drüben eine
zweite fahne an und geben ein bisschen
olivenöl hinein und da gebe ich in das
wasser hat die kartoffel für zehn
minuten
hier muss mich jetzt schmeckt wie man um
die sache schien das heiße öl haben und
zwar 3 knoblauchzehen und dann euch noch
was vom grossen rat den ich so etwa ein
ast weil es mir davon die blätter ab und
dann rosmarie klandt wir wollen aber
nicht dass der knoblauch und verbrennt
führen das ganze mit ein bisschen mehr
oliven und das öl sich jetzt so in
houston ist gehe ich auch mit der hitze
runter in die letzte panne habe ich
jetzt eine zwiebel julien streiten und
karamellisieren sie während der gesamten
zeiten der erstes vorbereiten
so gehen wir ein bisschen butter hier
hinein und dazu so zwiebeln und die
bleiben jetzt aber stehen ausschütten
wie mal die vorgekochten trocknen dann
geben wir sehen eine schüssel und mit in
die spitze kommt das öl von rosmarin und
knoblauch und das ganze schmeißen jetzt
ein bisschen hin und her
damit ist so ein bisschen die kartoffel
püree außenrum bekommt die schlägt
einfach nichts diese kartoffeln so sieht
das ganze dann aus und das bewahren wir
auch weil wir geben es am ende wieder
dazu bahnhof 230 grad vor gehalt geben
wir sie auch schon drauf ist dort ein
wie kartoffeln so dass jeder für sich
selbst liegt und wie der backofen zu
weiter geht's mit unseren sorger verwies
ich habe hier 500 gramm hackfleisch das
pferd ich jetzt mal nämlich genauso bei
125 gramm
hätte man die mir seit dem super-gau
werden nur 133 welchen hackfleisch kommt
ab und
buck passiert runter und von hohem wert
drauf wollen nicht formen damit die
partie
ok jetzt scheinbar schon rund wir
blicken jetzt einfach mal alle kartoffel
kaymer auf 20 minuten die bürger bereit
ich hier mit diesem opti grill zu auf
stufe manuelle dass die heißeste ich
hatte auch mal so ein ding war alles
cool ist aber noch einmal wir einfach
kaputt gegangen dementsprechend so lange
funktioniert ist gut schlechte qualität
aber so das ist jetzt vorbei ist jetzt
mal ein bisschen hier schon die bürger
brötchen an
er weist auf jeden fall von einer seite
sind die schon mal komplett vor
die kartoffel schauen wir auch richtig
gut aus nehmen wir auch schon unser test
gegen die auf und hatten so die zwiebeln
sind jetzt richtig schön karamellisiert
und darüber streicht ein bisschen habe
ich mir überlegt vierten käse schmelzen
so ein bisschen mit an zu legen ich noch
ein paar ästchen thymian
ich habe mark jetzt auch schon die hitze
komplett ausfällt dann kommt sogar noch
etwas honig so das sieht soweit gut aus
an dem ihr obendrauf sandwich käse in
den ritzen an schmerzen die ich jetzt
schnell die bürger bräuchten hier
dem barbecue sauce burke kann sich hier
über und da oben drauf schauen hier
römische in anderen käsesorte zwiebeln
und wir sehen uns gleich ein angerichtet
es wird auch hier gibt es wie gezeichnet
dankeschön der auch den kartoffeln in
börger ich habe mich bei den saucen
bedienen
dadurch auch wieder so richtig schmecken
du kennst ihn sprachen gern den ersten
biss oder die erste gabe und dann sehen
wie respekt was ein traum wird auch auf
dem freien markt ist sehr schnell aber
ich denke jeder der schon mal mit mir
etwas gegessen hat 100 meter haben mit
mir essen mag wird das zu bezeugen
können dass die geschwindigkeit in der
ich mein essen zu mir nehme etwas
überdurchschnittlich ist ein es war
extrem lecker und hamburgers und ich
meine gesagt ich hätte ich im reißen
könnte immer und bei dem gericht jetzt
war das war das brötchen sehr dieses
korps schwarze eingekauft hat extrem gut
und wir sehen das auch noch bei viktoria
das fleisch der mittels rosa und
normalerweise hier schon was
gemacht hat weiß dass es ein bisschen
schwieriger ist reinschauen und das
heißt so seelig kommt und weil natürlich
darf man nicht vergessen
die kartoffel hat das a10 von 10
dort also heute mich sagen also ich
könnte mich daran gewöhnt kunst
verpassen also haben dreimal zehn von
zehn leute genau erzählen heute gefahren
durch kammer ist richtig schön habe mich
sehr willkommen gefühlt hier direkt am
anfang habe ich auch noch so ein
bisschen kaffee und sonst was schon ein
bisschen erfahrung und so ein richtig
cooler tag bin auch selbst sehr
überzeugt
reiseziel von 10 ist wirklich toll und
wir heute sehen uns am nächsten sonntag
14 uhr spätestens wieder zur nächsten
folge persönlicher körper